bueno escogía álvaro por que creo que
representa muchas de las personas que he
retratado durante mi carrera
yo he sido un migrante he estado
viviendo en varios lugares del mundo y
siento que cuando uno se va pues deja
deja mucho en el camino y mi interés
artístico fue de como adentrarme en la
vida de este hombre me interesé mucho en
él cuando me dijo que llevaba 45 años
sin venir a colombia y la película
básicamente lo que hace es acompañarlo a
colombia y pues acá se da cuenta como de
la conclusión de que ya no es como en
ningún lugar creo que es un tema muy
humano que nos toca a todos y estoy muy
contento de lanzarla con colombia por
fin
cómo conoció a su personaje principal
álvaro y cómo trabajaron para grabar
este documental
bueno lo conocí en la calle como siempre
yo soy como fotógrafo callejero siempre
camino las ciudades con la cámara y lo
conocí por casualidad en el 2013 en
chinatown en nueva york' y empezamos a
crear una amistad que creo que él
también
fue como productor de esta película nos
acompañamos durante todo el tiempo allí
y me empecé a dar cuenta de muchos
factores en su vida muchas soledades
rasgos pero también una gran fuerza como
como de vivir y creo que álvaro nos
enseñan otras maneras de vivir pero
también una reflexión certera de todo lo
que uno gana o pierde cuando deja su
país y entendido usted sobre la postura
del migrante latino en eeuu con este
encuentro
he entendido que primero somos yo creo
que somos más maravillosos no lo bueno
inmigrante se ha enfrentado a muchos
desarraigo sin iniciarse pues como que
se desconectan de sus cosas pero ganan
otras cosas sin embargo yo personalmente
he sido migrante y ha tenido como la
suerte y la oportunidad de volver a
colombia siempre
pienso que hay un gran ejercicio de
valentía en esas vidas y vi como esa de
esa fuerza de tener que seguir adelante
lejos me parece que es de admirar y esta
historia habla un poco de eso y también
un mensaje es pues saber que no todo es
color de rosa no el sueño americano y yo
lo he podido ver y lo he vivido entonces
puede llegar a ser muchas cosas y muchas
veces pensando que se va a ganar también
se puede perder mucho creo yo y ahora
qué piensa usted como artista cuando ve
esas caravanas que cruzan el país de
méxico para intentar entrar a eeuu cuál
es su sentimiento
en el ciento de todos siento
siento admiración también por personas
que siguen no van van con sonrisa ya
quitando como la parte moral de esto o
entrar a juzgar siento que son muy
valientes y engañados un poco de lo que
creen que van a encontrar allá porque no
creo que sea fácil y sobre todo
caminando
pero pero bueno hay muchos que lo logran
y creo que es una situación del mundo y
de la sociedad hay que hay que verla me
da gran interés por estas personas
también y de verdad les deseo lo mejor
siempre y espero pues que todo el que
sus deseos se cumplan o por lo menos que
estén a salvo en este camino en esa
travesía